[Musique]
le maître vielles liste ici n'est pas
celui que l'on pourrait croire le
prodige de la vielle à roue c'est lui
grégory jolivet il a débuté
d'instruments à l'âge de 12 ans à
bourget et ils ne sont qu'une dizaine à
l'enseigné en france
[Musique]
ma première classe de vieilles stars
henrichemont en fait j'ai toujours fait
moitié-moitié en fête concerts et
enseignants avec jean-pierre il répète
une mazurka de la musique trad qui
suscite toujours dans le berry
l'engouement de passionnés la passion
c'est déjà l'instrument parce que
effectivement on fait corps avec
l'instrument c'est esprit festif qu'on
retrouve au château d'ars qui permet en
fait de tout se regroupent et quelles
que soient les générations grâce
effectivement à des professeurs comme
comme greg en fait qu'il y avait une
tout on veut dire de modernité voilà
dans la tradition toujours
de la tradition à l'expérimental
la vielle à roue dont les premières
traces remontent à plus de mille ans
grégory jolivet la révèle aux sonorités
électro
comme cette dernière compo aquatique
dixit inspiré de sa pratique de l'apnée
[Musique]
j'utilise le côté acoustique de
l'instrument donc sans effet et après
j'utilise un pédalier composé de
quelques distorsions de reverb virtuose
grégory compte parmi les joueurs
deviennent les plus courus d'europe
il a déjà collaboré à une trentaine
d'albums dernier en date celui du fameux
groupe de folk anglais blues à bella
[Musique]
dans les eaux
j'ai connu l'un de mes maîtres à jouer
quand j'étais ado qui est nagl eaton qui
était levier liste de
de gloses abela on a passé du temps à
jouer ensemble et j'ai aussi appris à
jouer dans son style et c'était mon
groupe préféré en fait quand j'étais
enfant dans les répertoires proposé par
blues avait là il n'y avait pas que de
la musique anglaise y avait de la
musique de l'est y avait aussi de la
musique française et notamment de la
musique du berry et du bourbonnais
arrivée dans la campagne berrichonne
après la révolution française la vielle
à roue a fait grâce au génie de grégory
une entrée c'est certain dans son
deuxième millénaire
dans les prochaines années je vais plus
à l'est vers un domaine que j'adore qui
est la musique expérimentale et
improvisées j'adore faire la musique sur
place me poser dans un dieu
et concevoir la musique sur le moment
[Musique]